يا إلهي ، وضع العصا لأسفل ،
وهذا ما اعتقدت أنه كان رائعًا جدًا ، لقد
حصلت على أبيض كبير جدًا يا إلهي ،
تمتلك عائلة كينان الذيل تمامًا
لإخبار زيارة فورت لودرديل من
ماساتشوستس أنهم قرروا الذهاب للصيد ، حيث
يحب كامبل كينان الصيد جيدًا  لقد
كان يومًا بطيئًا جدًا كنا
نصطاد للتو بعض أسماك الطُعم ، ثم فجأة
شيء كبير جدًا عندما
بدأوا في لفها لأول مرة في سحبها ،
كنت مثل
هل هذا الشيء سوف يسحبني
لأنني كنت للتو  خوفًا من أننا اضطررنا إلى التمسك
به ، كان علينا التأكد من أنه لن
ينزل من القارب وكان عليه التمسك بالبكرة
وكان مقيدًا
ولكن ليس حقًا ، فقد كان الأمر
مخيفًا لكامبل لمدة 12 عامًا فقط  SAT القديم
واستمر في القتال بمساعدة
الكابتن بول بالوتشي وديفيد جاكسون ،
استغرق الأمر وقتًا 45 دقيقة أو
ساعة للقبض عليه ، علمنا أن لدينا
شيئًا
مهمًا جدًا من اللقمة الأولية ،
استغرق الأمر حوالي 300 ياردة.
قاتل حتى تنتهي المعركة ،
كما تعلم ، لقد حدث ذلك ، لقد كان
شابًا أبيض رائعًا ، إنه أبيض رائع هذا
يشبه حفرة في واحدة في لعبة الجولف ،
إنه مثل أكثر ما في العالم ، كنت
متحمسًا جدًا له لأنه  يحب الصيد
كثيرًا وهذا أفضل ما
يمكن أن تتخيله على الإطلاق ، وبمجرد أن اكتشفنا
أنها كانت طريقة رائعة ، فقد كنا فقط
من خلال
الرجال الذين أقوم بذلك منذ عام 2003 ، وهو
ثاني واحد فقط من هؤلاء.  لقد
اشتعلت من أي وقت مضى صيادًا يلفها
لإخراج الخط من فمه ثم
قياسه ثم وضع علامة عليه أقل بقليل
من 11. طول 130 بوصة كان حوالي
450 رطلاً واه ،
سمحت لها الأنثى الجميلة بالرحيل إنها لا تزال حيوية جميلة
نحن  لقد تعرضت للهجوم الذي قاموا بوضع علامة عليها حتى يتمكن
الخبراء من دراسة أنماط هجرتها ،
ثم سمحوا لها بالذهاب إلى هناك ، إنها
تذهب إلى هناك ، تشعر أنها كانت تحقق إنجازًا كبيرًا ،
أعني أنها أكبر سمكة قد
اصطدتها من قبل قبل أن تكون عبارة عن سمكة متعرجة مقاس 25 بوصة ،
هذا هو
قام رجل صغير من سمكة قرش بيضاء كبيرة بحجم 130 بوصة بعمل رائع ، حيث
صادف أنه كان طريقة رائعة
كانت تجربة رائعة